as our good friend Cognito would say we
are live this evening so hello everyone
and welcome to the roundtable with the
stream team where we are gonna talk to
some amazing content creators and their
journeys on what they're doing today and
why they're doing it so today we have
l-boogie Oh - oh wait welcome to the
roundtable she is one of our co-hosts
also we wanted to take these next couple
of weeks to introduce ourselves they
should tell you guys why we're why we're
doing this why we wanted to become
content creators why we brought up this
podcast and why we wanted to share it
with all of you so well what I want to
tell you guys first is l-boogie is our
first guest she is one of the first
people that walked up to myself and
asked me to become part of this dream
team and she has always been a constant
backing for pushing us to want us to do
our weekly streams now our next
individual is is old school style he is
another one of our our co-hosts he has
been he's been doing this also about as
long as obligee and myself and he is a
great addition to the team and we have
our our young Lord as people would call
them we have MJ as a boss who's also
here to you know kind of talk with us
and see what why he is why he's doing
this as he's sitting in his college dorm
room right now chillin so l-boogie why
did you become a why did you want to
become a content creator
all right so well first off hello
everyone and probably just because like
I'm already gaming a lot and I felt like
there should be a space for people like
me who are moms that you know can watch
and engage with other people like
themselves I know that early on when I
started playing online I tended to have
a lot of backlash I guess because you
know you can hear my kid in the
background and whatnot people would be
like very upset to hear that so I was I
just thought to myself there has to be a
space for other moms be able to play and
you know we all know the deal
so it's not an issue so yeah that's
pretty much why I start streaming so so
when when did you end up you know
deciding to do this is a couple years
ago um so I think it was at when mixer
was stilled beam um and I was at e3 and
I was talking about a few people and we
just felt like if we were gonna dip our
toe in like we should start as soon as
we could when Microsoft purchased mixer
just to kind of get your foot in the
door a little easier just because of how
like twitch and YouTube was you know it
they already had their cemented people
there and it's kind of hard to progress
in those other categories so that's why
I decided to do mixer now you also are
you also do other podcasts with other
lady streamers correct right so I do
grow women gaming on Saturdays with
three other females Lady infamous
Delilah HD and Cherise so what was like
when you started to stream and you start
to start the podcast and things like
that when when did you think that like
this was something you were
like all than for you were gonna enjoy
things that you were gonna enjoy doing I
mean it mainly became like a hobby for
me I I never thought that it or think
still that it's anything that's gonna be
you know like it's not gonna be a
profession for me but I think that it is
a great hobby it learning how to do all
this stuff you know it adds skills and I
love fooling around with computers I
love playing games so it's kind of just
like easy easy road to go down you know
right right I was gonna say it hey
everyone old school there so l-let me
ask you this because yeah I think a lot
of people might find these particular
this particular portion difficult how do
you find the time between via tomorrow
and the stream and and then you we all
know that we try to find time just a
game offline so we can try to not have
to worry about having to tell everybody
everything we're doing how do you manage
that well I have to say that like now is
the hardest just because I'm in
transition but I I dropped my daughter
off at 8:45 and then I go to the gym so
then I know that I should be able to be
home by 10:30 so I can start a stream
from 11:00 to 1:00 and that is time that
I have blocked out for me this is the
time that I'm playing and if I'm playing
I'm streaming and it's time that I'm not
taking away from my child or other
duties you know so it was basically
because I'm not working at the moment um
I was able to block out that time now
it's gonna get a little harder for me to
do that since I'm starting a new job but
we'll figure out how that works did you
do you feel like um do you have like
that thought mentality of like if I'm
gaming like why don't I be stream
because I'm gonna be doing it anyway I'm
gonna be gaming anyway right I try to
even though sometimes I'm just dead dog
tired
you know like I don't want to interact
with anyone I just want to go like kill
things on TV and you know be content but
I do try to tell myself that just
because it is so hard for me to find
time to stream so it's like if you're
gonna be playing you need to be
streaming although I do think a set
schedule is the best for streamers you
know like every day I set inner you know
well you talk about them for those types
of individuals that want to produce like
a full write like a full career out of
it
yeah I mean I don't think that you have
to necessarily want to make a career out
of it in order to still want to progress
but that's probably just me because I'm
competitive so like I still want to be
good at what I'm doing what what type of
like challenges did you face when you
started to you know when you started
streaming and when you started to you
know doing that the podcast and all of
that so when I first started I had like
nothing you know so the biggest
challenge was just buying certain things
at a time so that uh I could build it so
when i first started streaming i was on
just through the xbox so xbox made it
like so easy for me to start because i
could just start on my xbox you know and
stream straight from there but there was
no camera but that [ __ ] baited also safe
filling for me too and then i had a
laptop so i started the podcast on there
but it was really just like jump in you
know and that's kind of how I've always
been I'm always been that type of person
where when I say that I want to do
something I just jump in severs mm-hmm
now would you say that you starting the
the all of this you you had these the
kind of like a plan to kind of like you
know step on to doing something else for
it from it or was it just one it was
just one of those like you said just a
hobby or did you like wanted to but when
some for myself personally when I
started when I started streaming I
wanted to kind of get a little out of my
shell like I was I believe it or not
which people are very surprised about I
was very introverted and when doing
streaming actually helped me to be able
to communicate more people be able to be
able to interact more be able to
communicate and did you did you have
some type of reason for what for wanting
to do it I mean my main reason was like
I said I wanted to create like the
little community I think my military
background like definitely makes me want
to have a community of people around me
so I wanted to make that little niche
out for anyone who was oh you know like
me even dad's you know dads are the same
way you know they have kids they want to
be able to game and people talk crap you
know about when they hear your kids are
stuff in the background so just like to
make like a safe safe space but just
like you even though people don't
believe it like I have a hard time like
interacting with people I guess you know
like camera shy type of thing but so
like I said when I first started on Xbox
it was so much easier because there was
no camera so it really I really had to
pump myself up to start being in front
of the camera I guess that's what I was
just gonna yeah is the struggle is real
yeah like how did you be and how
instills still to this day I still have
I still have moments with it how do you
manage knowing that everybody's out
there judging you in one way or another
goodbye and deeper yeah I mean you kind
of have to at some point just say eff it
right like you have to just for me like
I just say I know that there's gonna be
people that are gonna say
something so just know that if it comes
up to try not to lose your cool and to
write it off you know like I don't know
like you said so there's always someone
that's gonna say something there's gonna
be I think there's gonna be more people
that have nicer things to say though
then the negative people yeah how do you
how do you deal with those negative
people because I know you're any move
right it's exactly what I do same thing
because like when you start feeding into
that you go down I'm Alice's whole real
quick you know so I just block them or
boot them from my channel and keep going
you know it's the easiest way to deal
with it so what are you using for gear
now we all started out with basically
nothing legit right like so what do you
what are you wrong with your system now
because I've seen you streams and
they're pretty tight okay otherwise they
there's very few hiccups and that's
usually an Internet
on my side so alright I'd be curious to
know what what you were you're at now
with it so the biggest thing was
upgrading my internet so like my speeds
now so I found out that the speed needs
to be higher for my computer than the
Xbox right because the Xbox is like
throttled out you know it's the the I
guess the adapter that they use isn't
allowed to take in like high amounts of
data at the same time so like I usually
top out on my xbox at 300 to 400
megabytes usually less though and then
in my house in general like I have about
900 close to a gig coming in up and down
so that helps a lot yeah that helps a
lot
that that goes straight to my hard wired
into my desktop I went out and bought
like a cheapy gaming desktop and I have
two monitors just 1080p monitors
although I want to upgrade the one that
I actually play my xbox on to a 4k uhd
because like we're getting way more
beautiful
I feel like I'm doing injustice well
cleaning them on a 10-8 if you wanted
yeah yeah I find that also you know the
some of the games now that are coming
out they're graphically beautiful and
right you know you know PC Xbox it does
it I feel like it doesn't matter anymore
and those graphics is like you know you
want you want that immersion you want to
be part of those things did you did you
find like do you find yourself like
wanting to like be so immerse to the
point where you want to be like doing VR
the only reason why I don't want to do
VRS because then it's harder for me to
interact with people mm-hmm
because even though it's like a battle
to like make sure I'm paying attention
to the show I still like to interact
with people you know um I'd be worried
about
oh yeah I'd be like I'd be like smashing
stuff I'd be like looking crazy just
breaking things
watch that so like for me I'm like if I
fall it's for entertainment so whatever
I'm not gonna be that person who like
falls on purpose but yeah like all good
fun right yeah el gato hd60 is just to
finish with what old school is asking
but I have no God o HD 60s but I'd like
to upgrade so that I can get 4k
streaming out this tops out at 1080 60
frames per second and then I like to get
better with my audio right now I have a
Yeti hooked up to a boom hooked up to my
computer and then I use the Astro a40 s
which is also hooked to my PC so I do
the game chat through the Xbox app on my
PC oh so that's so that's how you end up
doing cuz I that Xbox app you know if
King heard me now he would be so mad
like I have such a problem every time
trying to use it through the computer I
don't know what it is yeah so like I
have the Xbox app and the Xbox beta app
and now the game bar and the game bar
usually works pretty well
yeah the game bar usually works pretty
well although some when it first came
out I was having issues um but yeah I
try to use the game bar the most because
it's easy you just press you know the
little Microsoft button in G pop right
up it also has your performance right
there so tell you how much your CPU GPU
Ram you're using and also has your audio
so that I'm able to regulate quickly
with like OBS in my system sounds or you
know whatever is going on you know that
was like the worst one of the worst
parts of streaming or trying to set
about your setup is the audio yeah I
can't I can't tell you how many hours
I've tried to not wring out my hair like
just try to get it all working yeah and
sometimes I'll turn on my computer it's
just like oh no we don't want to do that
today what did you do like did you not
close something right or was there some
update that now clashes with everything
else so that's why I don't play on PC
that's that almost seems like you know
that the problem did you now I got a
it's an interesting question did you
play Gears 5 yet of course you know I
played it on Wednesday at the launch
event in LA right oh I did not know that
were you invited to go to that or you
just you just sign up you sign up one of
the things they were doing was giving
people tattoos so like you signed up for
the whole kaboodle and then they drew
names and certain people that do it like
real tattoos or you're talking like that
I got that's too much real tattoos
that's too much I mean if they were
gonna do are really cool and I'm fine
with that but it seems like everybody
who got to do that that wasn't like a
voice actor or one of the creators of
the game got like a standard like okay
so you get to choose from these four and
then that's what you get to put on so I
wasn't down with it
like I don't want to be able to have a
cool ass tattoo to not just
a stamp you know right you played it you
put it on the Xbox not the PC yeah so
I've only played on the Xbox my pc isn't
beefy enough like I'm gonna have to
start upgrading it to be able to play
like on PC because I do want to try to
get into some destiny now that we're
able to like bring our characters over I
want to try to do someone PC oh pretty
cheap to upgrade right now extra money
even though I'm already you know I have
no control but if I did I would direct
you down the avenue of AMD processor
with an ace x4 70-mile rewarded
life is good what do you see like so I
think the processor in the motherboard I
have is decent right now I think it's
like the rise in oh those are beautiful
right so like even though this computer
was like a chibi one like it had a
really good processor in it which is why
I bought it
I think the biggest thing for me is to
put a better graphics card in there
oh when in some more memory yeah so what
is what is your favorite gaming or all
right yeah I've been playing as a
present way I mean right now five years
just that yeah I mean I'm sorry I was
gonna say like visually it's like
amazing and I didn't play three in above
like so I like I'm only playing four and
five so like my cousin likes to make fun
of me because he's like you've only
played the bad gear game but I like it
and I'm not the type of person that's
gonna go back and play because for one I
feel like the only reason why you like
the old ones is because of nostalgia you
are having other feelings that go into
that game as far as like that was the
first time you ever saw something like
this you did something cool for the
first time on this game so that's why
you love the old
you know like when you go back and play
it's clunky it doesn't look good I'm not
down for that do you notice that there's
just huge resurgence of like you know
the revamping of games like oh yeah it's
it feels like it's it's to the point now
where like even when they just brought
like wow classic back and it also did it
with what does that other can be just
all like Resident Evil I mean they're
all these resurgence of all these old
amazing games that are coming right in
these new graphics you know we're gonna
have Final Fantasy 7 soon and yeah I
know addicts gonna hate me for saying
this but I'm kind of excited to have
that action type combat whereas back in
the day was that turn-based combat
because the turn-based combat even
though I do enjoy it I feel like with
this new version of of 7 it's gonna give
those the newer generation those feels
to want to look you know want to do more
I want to play a little better
I don't play old games I don't know I
tried people have bought people have
bought games for me and I load them up
and I'm just like me I don't know what
to tell you I don't get it like I don't
know that style sure is a hell of a drug
it is and it's a great brush in that I
get where you coming from though and I
think there's a lot more yeah this is a
Channel World Games roll it out and go
ahead there's something you got to play
you got to play back Resident Evil 2 1 C
I don't think I really do scary games
either although I am gonna try it just
for this channel because I know people
are gonna want to like watch you scream
you know I do I do know that old school
will sit there and play Resident Evil 7
all day like I've seen I saw I watched
him play it and like he had fun with it
and I know that like since we do a lot
of the
the reviews on the ILP channel like I
know MJ had had a great scary game I'm
playing it was a layer on Resident Evil
7 in the VR hell no I'm not mess with
that book I got halfway through that
game in the VR now I'm not doing it
again
ya see I don't see how people like
torture themselves with it like I'm good
I don't really do those either like I'm
totally the person that comes home and
has nightmares so dude do you have like
a favorite game that you enjoy streaming
that you like all right this is my go
game this is the one I want to do apex
apex yeah no more pub G no poop G I
don't think so
I got piss because I feel like pub G on
the console is an afterthought I feel
like they took their money from
Microsoft and they don't care about like
making that game as good as the PC
that's very true though right I feel
like it's like the stuff they're doing
you like it's too little too late you
know like you giving us Chrome's like
I'm good so I could play Peck's
and it's awesome did you guys see meds
video about the gears v like the
comparison between PC and Xbox no I did
not it was hard to tell the difference
yeah I heard that it looks awesome on
the X yeah on the PC like it doesn't
really like well my garbage on the Xbox
one X and that's what I played on so
mmm-hmm I'm I'm a scrub I still play on
is that's the way I my standard Xbox if
I mmm I'm looking I'm looking at my mind
right now and I'm just like I have so
much stuff on top of it because I almost
never play it anymore because I write
I'm sick you see wow did you just call
yourself out as a fraud
I'm not a fraud I say all the time pc
masterrace oh that many times Lord what
game really got you
- like stream the most mainly any
shooter like I'm gonna stream any
shooter um it's just in me I guess you
know I had a good time doing shooters or
actually shooting in the military and I
absolutely love shooters so anytime a
new shooter comes out that's what I'm
streaming a new Call of Duty I'm getting
called booty mm-hmm believe niche
bleeding-edge yes I'll get that - I
played that e3 is nice it was fun I
don't know quite yet if I'm going to get
what's the one movie saw talk about oh
my god break point yeah I'm not sure I
get that
so I soften or yeah I I am too and I
normally buy that one and it's like
really crazy that I'm actually thinking
about getting call of Booty over that
but I I was in the beta this past
weekend and you know it's it's open open
NDA so I can talk about it and it it
felt good but it didn't push me to want
to buy it I mean I yeah I have wildlands
and really I really enjoy playing
wildlands and now that I'm I kind of
played you know break point I was just
like like am I gonna actually play it or
is it gonna be like wild and just sit in
my in my inventory and not yet III does
you see I got to play it for like two
hours because my buddy and it's just
like I feel like if I were to buy it
you're just kind of sitting on the shelf
for a while
I play it for like a week yeah touch it
yeah I kind of just feel like
I'd rather buy it on a discount you know
yeah
but call of duty and I'm gonna get Star
Wars because I'm a big star Wars fan I'm
not a big like story junkie Star Wars
fan where I'm gonna tell you they're
loaded Yodas head was like tilted 35
degrees is movie like I'm not gonna I'm
not that type of person but I appreciate
Star Wars for what it is you're gonna be
on the borderlands bandwagon no I'm not
gonna play that a 1c the borderlands is
coming out tomorrow is it not Friday
Friday so I'm actually I have I've seen
so many people posting about it and
stating back you know Borderlands is
under what what were you saying before
MJ it was a NDA on it was so lock and
key right what were you saying before
about the Borderlands the the people
that were posting about it that wasn't
me
no I know I was telling you that the
they had limited releases even within
the US and they are not releasing game
codes on it from what I've heard
they for people to access it that's an
access the game and play it they got to
go through the epic store they given
reviewers a special access
I sold level on the ethics tour and
they're telling them not to play on the
direct x12 as well so to me it sounds
like the game is not ready for Showtime
and that I guess that James has tweeted
that they didn't send Windows central I
guess a cold for 40 minutes sorry
yeah and I mean they're pretty big
windows central they usually get all the
games so yeah I saw the tweet also from
from Jess that's kind of I was like huh
I was like one of these days we're gonna
have to talk to him and see if we can
get him to talk about stuff because I
you know that whole etheral side is kind
of very very interesting that you know
they wouldn't give a code like that to
them was very surprising like when we
were at
ceased they seemed like the coolest guys
in the world like this and that was one
of those things that Randy Pitchford
kind of like was he's he's one of those
CEOs you could tell that you want
backing you I mean he was and he's good
and it was like I was like huh I was
like it really makes you think like what
what the background of this of this you
know of Gearbox's like and I really was
good yeah this is the same company
though that went after I can't remember
which youtuber was for a kind of leaking
information and they showed his YouTube
channel down yes right well that's what
once people start breaking NDA is I mean
that's just you know if you like the
whole thing with gears v like if they
was like the guys were talking about an
ILP this past week when ninja was doing
curious v like in he had that that
pre-order the early copy you know he was
just like I'm not starting it until
exactly this point because I don't want
to get in trouble by it and I feel like
most of the NDA's now are so locked down
that most streamers and most content
creators are so worried because like
that's that's their livelihood like one
problem and you know that's everything
of theirs it's gone
right but this is the the youtuber they
shut down wasn't under an NDA all he was
was just reporting the leaks that were
already out there from other news
outlets and they went after him like
there's a whole story behind it they had
people show up at his door it was I
don't know what they're trying to hide
it's not like Borderlands 3 is this big
secret at this point all right but yeah
men and black showing up at your door
there's a problem with something great
definitely definitely definitely are you
uh are you planning on going to any
conventions or anything this anymore
this year were you planning for next
year uh yeah well since I'm gonna be on
the East Coast go to PAX East now Oh
Cognito just here that we may have
another person for PAX East for us right
yeah I'm definitely gonna go to Patsy's
because I've never been to a pax and
even though I've gotten into packs with
like you know what someone's like hey I
have tickets you can come it always ends
up being like something true you know
why I can't go and I was gonna try to go
to Texas um but it just never worked out
so now I'll be on the East Coast
well there's there's two East Coast ones
there's the the the video game one which
is PAX East which has board games and
video and video games which I will say I
go to every year that is like my
convention that is that in the words of
MJ that's my jam
like I like that's the one that I love
going up to the I feel like it's it's
what a video game convention should be
like feeling like I've also never been
to an e3 so I will totally the whole
zone information but they also have
packs unplugged in Philly okay well
that'll be pretty close to you yeah so
pax unplugged is mostly just straight
board games okay
yeah which is actually really really
cool like a I or games like for myself I
I play a bunch of different ones I play
I do play Dungeons and Dragons you know
we try to do that like once every every
couple of weeks and then like Ticket to
Ride this game called dungeon this don't
we have so many like it's it's crazy
like we're running out of space
the only other I don't I don't know if
you call it a board game but the only
thing I've ever played is Magic the
Gathering the card game card game I have
you have you ever tried the computer
version of it yeah I think I did better
on the little video game I did on the
actual car game mm-hmm yeah
so I don't know I don't I've never
gotten into the Dungeons & Dragons I
never really had enough geeky people
around me to even play that um so I mean
it's not like I wouldn't play just never
had anyone to play with drew you into
playing video games though because most
of us it was a logical progression of
like playing risk and all risk is on the
Commodore 64 yeah I just dated myself
and I'm yeah so for me my I had a my
dad's brother my uncle was um a VP for
IBM back in the day so he like kept
computers with us and every time I will
visit like they all had all the new
video games and stuff like that so I
Maxis is probably my all-time favorite
developer from when I was a child like I
had all the sim games sim ant SimCity
all that good stuff um but yeah I I hate
it risk like I always remember getting
stuck did not be another Chris
and it was another one I can't remember
the name right now that was like puzzle
like that but yeah so playing on PC and
then my father had an Atari when I was
younger I've had every game console come
through my house I had a Sega I had a
Sega Genesis I had a Nintendo Super
Nintendo and I see no 64 and it's a
Gamecube we we you I've had all the
Nintendo systems all the Xbox's all the
Playstations all that [ __ ] which was
which was her favorite would you say um
[Music]
my favorite console of all time was
probably the most fun I had I guess is
what I should say it was on the Gamecube
and on the dream yes really
what what what drew you to the to the to
the Gamecube
so it was just a cheaper console I think
and we got it
I had an Xbox as well I used to play a
lot of what was that um they just came
out with a fighting game and I can't
remember a second oh this one with the
girls but huge boobs and I had like a
boob on Maneri yeah did her life so I
used to play that fighting game I played
that alright and I played the fighting
game and then I played a lot of like
whatever Mario was out at the time
whatever Zelda was out at the time and
then Super Monkey Ball right yes which
which one I don't remember the one for
for Gamecube I only remember the one for
we know there was one for Gamecube yeah
it was there is most Monkey Ball then I
guess because we came out after but it
was fun
lots of frustrating nights with that
yeah I remember those days great but
yeah
so L what's your what's your plan for
the future streaming like what do you
what games you're gonna be running down
over the next couple months because
there's a whole bunch coming out alright
so I already told you about Kali and
then I'll be playing destiny shadow key
because they just have their hands in my
pockets and I also really want to play
the outer worlds it looks like fallout
like the fallout we deserve yeah agreed
so I'm really intrigued with that I'm
down for that and then Star Wars that'll
be - end of the year right and then
gimme the year I'll be on that watchdogs
and cyber
mm-hmm yeah I restarted a watch those
run and I just there's something about
that game it's just like it's beautiful
yeah I played oh yeah and I just I was
just like I'm like I can't wait to get
my hands on the new ones just to see to
see it because they're they do such a
great job with that open world like
that's what I feel like
Ubisoft is most known for is their open
world the video games more you know I
played it at e3 that self-driving cars
what people who weren't even in it yeah
that's it's pretty nice yeah yeah I mean
I like watchdogs I like just because
it's like hacking and stuff right like I
don't wanna do that yeah so like my
favorite things that I like about
cyberpunk is that you're able to like
hack everything yeah so any thing like
that
computer computer geekiness and me comes
out do you think we'll be like GTA what
the online that's coming out yes I did I
think this I talked about that on my
podcast last week and I think that's
gonna be the only way that they're gonna
be able to have a multiplayer yeah cuz
if it's like GTA because I mean what do
we like doing battle Rio or something
like hey yeah how's that gonna work that
I thought that you could have had this
huge type of close-knit game with with
put it with adding that online like you
were saying with GTA because the last
two versions of watch those I felt like
that online ain't like what's the world
look for not uh the intrusions for when
they came into your game when other
players came into your game I felt like
it was kind of blah like I was like why
are these guys here and yes is kind of
boring
when like what made you like start
enjoying like Star Wars thanks to the
point where you're like I need to play
fall in order I mean I think that the
last couple Star
worst games we've had because before
that I played where were the ones on the
360 Force Unleashed oh yeah like you
played with the lightsaber and
everything in my those were fun as hell
yeah the tooth is too with Starkiller
yeah yeah I played the I didn't play
Knights of the Old Republic because I
was on PC but um this looks like an
actual story and I play well I didn't
get the plate they let us they let us
stand in line to watch a video at e3 um
[Music]
so I'm really looking forward to playing
actual story because the last two that
EA has put out have not been really
story based they've always just been
like hey this is how you play
multiplayer you know yeah it's all about
battlefront and this is Bo front yeah
yeah battlefront - yeah battlefront -
did get a little better once EA got
lynched with all the boxes but right
alright I hear what you saying there
wasn't much of a single-player campaign
and neither one of them yeah if you if
you get if you get time I would
recommend playing Knights of the Old
Republic on PC because IIM DUP playing
it and each story for each path you take
is different so you have eight stories
right there that you can play is 448 so
the the stories are all unique and
they're really really enjoyable and I
would definitely take that I take that a
little bit of time and do it because
you'll be you'll be surprised because I
can run it okay on my computer so I was
able to run mmm what's that really
pretty game that just came out well not
just but come with me to go it's Mass
Effect
Blair Witch no it's here in the snow
[Music]
worst worst worst chat with the answers
no it's not Watson it's on game path
ultimate 4pc only smell one I really
knows years five it's like kind of scary
there's monsters and crap
keep trying out the curse I think I know
what you're talking about about all this
cold yeah anyways I was able to run that
on the lower settings so yeah you
probably can yeah I mean it could that's
to the Old Republic I'm sorry uh the Old
Republic is it's it's old it's like over
ten years old so I mean if you can like
literally like run World of Warcraft's
you'll be fine I mean like it's
literally like it's like that old so
it's not that big a deal so I would
definitely like take it and they have a
free option that you can enter playing
and then you can like so you see if you
like it or not and if you want to then
you just Thursday have subscriptions
which unlocks so much more stuff to you
and that's like one of those things
that's really you know what's nice about
it I mean that's believe it or not
that's oh actually I actually have that
as my on hold screen because I love that
game so much nah you'll be fine you'll
be fine crappy
cause like I said I don't like playing
old games oh yeah it's not great but
it's not 8-bit if that helps you out any
so you're telling me you're more like
King I guess what is it you've
experienced yeah I don't have a Q lid
which that'd be the next thing I end up
getting because alright for me people
like to talk Oleg qulet everyone's eyes
are different everyone accepts
different for me brighter brights looks
better than darker darks it wasn't a
matter of you know I don't have enough
money for this or that I chose to get
aks 8000 which I guess it's like a mu
8000 now for Samsung because it's the
monitor that Xbox uses to show off the X
and I don't know I think it just looks
better for me yeah is there any like any
type of like hardware that you ended up
getting that was particularly to
yourself that you like I really really
want this like a lot of people thought
like oh I need to have alcott oh oh I
need to have you know Razer for this
that you know you know I mean was there
anything that you felt had to be a
preference to you probably this TV
although I don't play on it as much
because I play on the monitor so that's
why Sony now I'm like looking at what
monitor I want to get that's gonna be 4k
what's free sync and UHD and all that
good crap um but yeah so like that and
then I don't know I got the elgato key
light I actually won it on Twitter and
that is like a game-changer you you were
the individual that told me about it and
how amazing it was and I have the green
screen behind me and I had nothing but
problems with it running it and then you
were like you gotta get you you know
this thing is so good it's good and I
was thinking about and I was like mmm
and then I ended up getting it on your
recommendation and it was one of the
best decisions that I made because that
other than audio I felt like lighting
was a huge issue for me did you did you
feel that way when you setup your green
screen yeah so like when I had the green
screen like I had this like just little
lamp that I found in the house that like
was kind of to be so the light shone up
and it kind of did okay but once I got
the key light and like I played with the
settings and stuff like it just really
helps with any shadowing that you get or
any that graininess that you can get
with the green screen
um it just makes like a huge difference
and then because I'm like such a crazy
person when it comes to the stream we
also have the stream dick
so like I'm able to just change adjust
on the fly to ping on the light that's
coming into the house in general now you
end up you you use stream labs or OBS or
xsplit which do you prefer using as your
streaming software of choice so I was
usually stream labs for the longest
because I loved all their different and
overlays the one that and you can kind
of like tailor whichever one the way you
want and they have like widgets for like
pop-ups and I am able to like just enter
in whatever gifts that I want so I
really like that and whatever sounds you
want to come up so like for me when
people where people host me like this
gif of cup it comes up and it does that
thank you sound and so I think that's
pretty cool that they make it like
really accessible for you to do things
like that however something is wrong
with stream labs some type of update
happen and now when I stream all you
hear is like garbled static so I've been
streaming with OBS but the cool thing is
all my stream labs widget still work so
that's why I don't have overlay which is
kind of okay for me I don't really need
to have overlay right now um but yeah
all my like wit just still works so when
people follow me and all that good stuff
still comes in was is there which
widgets do you end up use them when do
you do it when the people follow you
when people host you tips yes I have I
have all those all three of those I when
I was streaming with stream lads I had
my tip jar next to me which I think
actually helped get tips I'm a little
jar out but um yes inside OBS I don't
have well since i'm using basic obvious
i haven't had two jar out so i'm gonna
have to figure out what's going on with
the slob so that I can start using again
I just haven't had time to sit down and
work things out and talk to their tech
support and stuff Tina that was always
my biggest complaint with slobs is every
time they did an update they broke
something right yeah that's what I don't
like to like it seems like every time
there's something different something
else happens so I'd like them to get
better with it and then they used to do
they used to do to support through their
discord and now I guess it's just like
not really support so you actually have
to go in and file a complaint so that's
that's a little annoying
right yeah do you know where do you
stand on like if when someone comes up
to you and they're like what we're where
should I start
what what do I need to strain like
what's the the first thing you tell them
is is key for first streaming for Xbox I
tell them you know if you want to stream
and you don't have anything you don't
have a lot of money he's just stream
straight from your Xbox everything's
there if you get a camera you're able to
plug it right in to your xbox although
at first I think I was using my Kinect
um but yeah so you can't turn on the
camera
plug it in you're good to go it's not
much investment and then like I said to
just really like try to have a set
schedule in tweet tweet out when you're
on so you can get people and try to find
groups I think that's a really good is
to find like Facebook groups or you know
things of that nature where you're able
to say hey guys you know I'm live so
that people start to come and watch
business cards help with that too once
you go out to like convention all right
yeah conventions you definitely have to
have business cards all right
tell people at all times but yeah and
it's pretty cool what I do is I do a QR
code that links you directly to my
channel interesting interesting
do you do you feel that networking is
one of the largest contributors to your
stream growth in your channel growth um
yeah because for the longest time it was
like I started to get one I streamed
regularly I get more randoms coming in
but for the most part it's the people
that I know that I've met through
Twitter through conventions things like
that to come to watch so and for me I
think that networking is like the key to
life so right right uh MJ did you did
you have any other questions you you
thought of to ESCO what was the first
game he ever streamed [ __ ] about me
start streaming three years ago or two
years ago did you stream off the console
at first or did you have an elgato how
did it all work yeah I we talked about
this I started just on the Xbox and then
I got an elgato and then I had it in a
lotto with like I was trying to do it
with my Mac and that was horrible yeah
and then finally I bit the bullet and
got a little PC and since then I've been
cooking with gas and then you know like
because I go to like the conventions and
stuff I get freebies so like I try to do
giveaways like I just gave away the year
of game pass ultimate so that helps
although I don't like to give stuff away
like constantly because then you get
those people who are just asking for
[ __ ]
if if you if oh man if you listened to
yesterday's podcasts with iron Lords
they gave away Borderlands 3 and Gears 5
and like I went through that list with a
fine-tooth comb of like people that
don't read the
climber like I said you can't you can't
be part of X Y & Z you can't do this
this and this I mean I literally I
started at 3 o'clock I'm sorry at 1:30
and I didn't end until like 3:30 for
going through these lists because people
were not leading those not reading those
you know those climbers and I mean I've
heard a lot of people have had a lot of
growth and a lot of good things that
happen from those things but I'm almost
to the point like you are like I want to
I want to give things to my channel I
want to give things to my to the people
that you know are the ones that are
backing me break there's so many people
out there that are just in it for the
free stuff it's almost like the other
people like the people that matter are
they they don't get a chance that's why
I like I when I gave the information to
solve and everybody yesterday I was like
you got to tell the people from ILP you
know you've got to go in on these like I
I mean gleam is good for me gleam is
good for getting people to like follow
you right yeah those are good but when
you want to give to like your community
so like when apex came out with season 2
I did like $10 codes in my channel first
so people could get the battle pass oh
it's beautiful
that's a great idea so I gave it out the
whole month of the first month July I
guess and if you were in my channel and
you were active I would drop a code so
or whisper the person a code and so to
me I think that's or you know you can do
like giveaways with slobs and stuff like
that where you like run a giveaway um
but yeah so to me that's the best way so
if it's like a big ticket item like a
video game or like I did the year of
game pass I'm gonna do gleam if it's
something smaller I'm gonna do it just
for my channel if I ever get big enough
to be partner up and I'll probably do
like you know sub only type giveaways -
yeah yeah old school did you have did
you have any questions were thinking
about well
no I think I've covered everything
actually no that's a lie do you have a
roadmap for your channel like where do
you see yourself in three months and I
know you got a lot going on so we're
gonna take this next month and throw it
throw it in the bushes yeah but where do
you see your channel on like three
months six months in another year like
where would you like to be um I would
like to say that I would like to be
partnered um but I have no specific
roadmap I'm just plugging away hopefully
people like my content type of thing you
know
mmm I enjoy your content yes I mean just
the ultimate goal like I said is to make
like a cool place where we can play
together and hang out that's it that's
my ultimate goal so as long as we're
doing it even if it's like three or four
people I'm good to go
yeah not looking for fame over here
knocks at the door you gonna answer
right I sure we know if if Maximus uh
what was that what was was King calling
them yeah my field yeah if if Phil comes
to it Phil comes with a bag of money
you're gonna take that bag of money so
why don't uh what is your like if you
could live in one video game universe
right what where would you want to be
where would you would you love to be
sitting in Hogwarts would you love to
sit like with you know Jedi's on
Coruscant where would you where we if
you could live in one of those fantasy
worlds hanging out with Lincoln Zelda
what kind of places would you want to be
and I'm not talking about just those
places I'm talking about I'm talking
about anything you could think of well I
would definitely want to be in Hogwarts
just because I
I've always been enamored with magic
like I think that it is hardly like the
next best thing to being like a
superhero you know to be able to like
contra magic so I would definitely want
to be in Hogwarts but I don't know if
I'd want to be in the game because all
of them suck I'm not talking about the
games really dragons and like cool
creatures and magic I'm all for it
so you were saying how much you love The
Sims games just me realize there is a
new sims pack coming out that is going
to be magic so you are gonna feel like a
person from Hogwarts they've actually
said I'm stop playing Sims games because
Sims was like how Wow was for a lot of
people like it was that game that like
had me on all day on Saturday like
didn't get up ate in front of the
computer like all that so yeah it's a
life life sucker it's fun it's fun
enjoyable it is fighting but like what
house real uh
workand or oh it's gotta be Gryffindor I
mean like I know people who are like
slithering them what I can't trust you
now because like you choose it yeah yeah
that was nice so uh so elf tell me so
tell us all here where where we can find
you your you know your your future
schedule which is probably what in two
to three weeks you know where where you
would tell us you know I made it super
easy for everyone I'm Elba neo 208
everywhere so on Twitter on mixer on my
xbox and on the PlayStation Oh buddy Oh
208
so in a couple weeks once I get settled
I'll probably start streaming at about 7
o'clock Eastern Time 6 or 7 o'clock
Eastern so yeah every day I'm excited
I'll I'll be there you'll see me old
school what about what about you right
now we're we're in a whole bunch of
transition like life never stops
movement help restore them but you can
catch me on the old school style and
this is where it's going to get dodgy
mixer on Xbox Playstation you can catch
me there on Twitch and old-school style
70 and just launched in the tech news or
Tech Talk Channel and that's under
schools tech taco day or on YouTube so
hopefully I'm going to get a bunch of
merch that would be able to start
getting away but I got a I got a big and
pander to the masses that the man of
fact it was that a lot that'll give it
away first a couple of weeks you know
we'll we'll have you expand on that good
sir
yes MJ what about you bug um so right
now I'm taking a break from streaming
and the past though I'd probably stream
from like 8 o'clock at night until 2 in
the morning on a school night but then
once I was working at get off at 2 and a
probably stream between 2 to 4 but right
now I'm taking a break because I've just
moved into college but sooner or later I
will get some hours and the schedule up
but you are screaming but you are super
active on the Twitter on Twitter yeah
I'm kind of active on Twitter yes my
Twitter is baby MJ right now and my
twitch is MJ is emboss if you'd like to
follow me
sounds good I am now though or as many
people call me Lord peat because no one
could ever pronounce my name
I am Snell doe on everything literally
everything and I would like to just say
thanks thanks everybody for you know
coming in you know thank you all the
viewers tonight for coming in we really
appreciate you guys coming in for our
our first
no roundtable with the stream team I
like to thank l-boogie for pretty much
jumping jumping in you doing doing our
first or first you know episode and yeah
it's it's been great so MJ he's going to
be getting up our our episode up on
iTunes and Spotify in addition to here
on YouTube next week we're gonna be
having a old-school style
come in and we're gonna we're gonna get
him with questions if anyone has any
questions and they feel that they want
to ask all school please email us at
roundtable stream team at gmail.com and
by all means follow us on Twitter and
this is this is a little weird because
our name is so large it is very very
very hard to to get that name so we
ended up picking table stream because it
was easy for everyone so if you're
looking for us we are at table stream on
Twitter and if you go there you'll see
us when we're going to go live when
we're what our new episodes are going to
be for our next guest and so on and so
forth
I apologize for us running a little late
tonight you know as it being our first
stream we had to kind of get the bugs
out and things like that and thank you
all for for doing you know for conferred
come and joining joining us and remember
everyone dream big and keep gaming have
a fantastic night and I will see
everybody and well I'll see everybody I
guess next week hopefully
alright thanks already but